Joe Biden's getting desperate because
Americans aren't buying his bomic
nonsense only 14% of Americans say
they've been helped by Biden's economic
policies and Trump's mopping the floor
with Biden on the issue up 20 points in
the latest poll Biden needs a villain to
distract Americans and convince them
that his policies aren't to blame so the
grumpy old gu is now taking his anger
out at greedy grocery stores for higher
prices but for all we've done to bring
prices down there are still too many
corporations americ
ripping people off price gouging junk
fees greed flation shrink flation we're
tired of being played for
suckers but wait it gets even dumber
Biden is going to war with Snickers for
shrinking the
bars about Snick what's happening with
the Snickers bars yeah Snickers bars you
know that candy well they haven't raised
the price of a Snicker bar they just
took 10% of it out
oh no no it's less smaller so that's how
they're making more
money correct yeah um did you know that
Snickers Shrunk the bars I have a theory
that he uh Came Upon the Halloween
Snickers the The Minis yeah the minis
and he's going what happened to the
Snickers and then they gave him some
soup and he went to bed you know I he's
calling American suckers for paying for
their groceries not all of us can steal
I I mean I'm not part of a gang that can
smash and grab a Target and steal 900
bucks worth of stuff so I guess we are
all suckers for paying but he he has no
concept of the economy he always blames
the outcome for the cause why would
stores I mean does he believe that St
stores artificially inflate the prices
when all they do is try to sell stuff as
cheap as possible that's their strategy
to compete does he think that they like
met and decided all the stores met go
you got to fix them we have to fix the
prices is that what he wants us to think
no the reason why we're having problems
is because of gas prices theft which is
amounting to the billions printing money
to give to other countries illegal
immigrants and student loan dead beats
Biden's boot voting block I mean he has
no concept of how an economy works and
he should actually thank like it's weird
he always goes after stuff that keeps
America afat Right grocery chains oil
border law enforcement he should thank
God for capitalism if we didn't have
food if we didn't have gas if we didn't
have cheap booze and Amazon and Netflix
the public would have seen through him
ages ago we got plenty of bread and
circuses to keep us going to not notice
it and it seems like there's this new
strategy they're all going to go after
gading here's Liz Warren
Dana from Doritos to oros to even toilet
paper these big corporations are
shrinking how much they give us
corporate Executives thought we wouldn't
notice but they're wrong we noticed it's
time to crack down on corporate greed
flation I'm fed up no pun
intended she needs that toilet paper
because she's full of what
crap a Dana I mean it really worked well
for her in 2020 this line of
argumentation plus do you remember Putin
price hike that was what he blamed on
gas prices and I think the one thing
that we do not talk about enough is how
the Biden administration's energy
policies have made everything more
expensive for all of us and that could
be for years to come unless it is
somehow reversed because a lot of these
uh companies make decisions now and they
look 10 15 20 years in the future and if
they don't think they're going to get
those permits approved they don't make
the investment which means you don't get
the jobs which means your energy prices
go up and your National Security goes
down Harold when you open up a bag of
potato chips and maybe there's like six
less chips than they're used to do you
feel ripped off by big chip I feel
grateful cuz you you see me every day
before the show slender but I eat a bag
of chips this is not the strategy that I
would be using uh I think that there
there number of other things that that I
think resonate more with with voters and
I've never been a believer in picking on
uh American companies be it be it oil
companies unless they've done something
illegal uh and I don't know what they're
doing I mean the the the agal message of
making communities safer making our
schools work better making prescription
drugs and Insulin cheaper uh protecting
our border and ensuring that Putin does
not Prevail uh in Ukraine that seems to
me something better to be ticking off uh
than taking on taking on a local
supermarket because there are number of
communities throughout America that
don't have supermarkets in their
communities you have food deserts in a
lot of cities and a lot of rural areas
across the country so I would change
that one up a bit you know this is a
direct direct attack on Judge Uncle
jeppis it is a direct attack on Uncle
jeppis and the judge Janine chocolate
Apple okay I'm glad you mentioned it and
I didn't okay look there's a reason that
Trump is mopping the floor with Biden in
terms of the economy people don't
believe the nonsense about biomics
people have to buy bread and milk and
cheese and meat and it's just it doesn't
matter what he's talking about he can
talk about bomic till the cows come home
the prices are staying hang up and the
truth is if he wants to blame remember a
couple years ago we blame big meat
remember that one there was the big meat
oh they're no good and if people are PR
uh price gouging Mr President uh get
your attorney general if he's not too
busy going after other people to
prosecute price scouts because that's a
crime and in the end the guy knows
nothing about the economy knows nothing
about business all he's done his whole
life is uh cash the check that he signed
on the back or that is son gave him but
I'm not going there Harold go Blue you
can go there it's fine hi everyone I'm
Brian killme I want you to do me a favor
I want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now